Has the CP officially left the nup The French Communist
Party has definitely broken with France insoumise.
We have uh Voted 1 statement National Council of our party 93% representative
uh Who uh A Finally who made the observation that so you wish?
Today?
PS was 1 and it was urgent That's why I would
like to say that to your listeners.
You want 1 new house of reconstruction It is
urgent to rebuild 1 union of the left,
1 gathering of the left capable of governing tomorrow,
bringing hope for the world of work So with the socialists,
with the ecolos and without the insubordinates,
and with and with all those and those the other political forces of the left,
ecologist who wish to participate in this gathering
and build this hope on the left,
and including with the insubordinate who are not found in
the statements of Jean-Luc Mélenchon.